[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
ARI WEINZWEIG: What's
a non-Google welcome?
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Well, first we
have to ask you a icebreaker.
And then it'll officially
be a Google welcome.
So Ari, could you
please start us out
with what is the secret
to a great sandwich?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well, I don't
think there's any secret.
I think everybody
knows the secrets.
It's just you start with
really good ingredients.
It's just most people
don't want to pay to buy
really great ingredients.
They want to use
average ingredients,
and it's impossible to make
something great out of average.
So I think that would
be a really good start.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Awesome.
Thank you for that.
All right.
Great.
So can you please go ahead and
take us off with who was Ari
before Zingerman's?
What's your story?
And how did this amazing
Ann Arbor infamous deli
come to be what we
know of it as today?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well, it's
a lot more than a deli.
How did it-- I guess I'm the
same person I always have been.
I think we just evolve.
In the same way Ann
Arbor is the same town
as it was 100 years ago--
it just grows and evolves.
And it's not a one-night,
overnight, change.
It's just you continue to learn.
But anyway, I'm from Chicago.
I grew up there, came
up here to go to school.
I went to U of M,
studied Russian history,
studied the anarchists.
Most of you don't know, but
we have the largest anarchist
collection in the country.
It is on the seventh and eighth
floor of the graduate library.
If they let you out of work
you could go down there
and check it out.
After graduating, I had no clue
what I was going to do next.
I mostly just didn't
want to go home.
In order to not go
home, I needed a job.
I'd driven a cab while I
was in school part-time.
That wasn't all that much fun.
One of my roommates was waiting
tables in a restaurant at
I don't know what it was--
Fourth and Liberty--
that's not there anymore.
And I went in there looking
for a job as a server.
And they told me they'd
call me if something opened.
And I waited two weeks,
and they hadn't called me.
So I went back, and I
reapplied as a busser.
And they said they'd call me.
And I waited two more weeks.
And they hadn't called
me, so I went back
and offered to do anything.
And they asked if I
wanted to wash dishes.
And I said, sure.
And that's how I got started.
So I wish I could tell
you some wonderfully
glamorous, entrepreneurial
story of a childhood filled
with great food, and my
mother was an amazing cook,
and I knew from
the time I was 10 I
was going to have my own place.
But none of that
is true whatsoever.
My mother was a good
person but not a good cook.
And I grew up on--
I always say it's
the mid-20th century,
but I think they
still sell it all--
Kraft macaroni and cheese, Mrs.
Paul's fish sticks, Pop Tarts,
Tang, Nestle Quik,
Cocoa Krispies,
Cocoa Puffs-- all that stuff.
So I had zero culinary
upbringing whatsoever.
And really, no one in my
family was in business.
They were all teachers,
doctors, lawyers, psychologists,
dentists.
So I was the total
failure of the family
for not getting an
advanced degree.
And in hindsight, I have more
empathy for my mother's angst
after I had four years
of out-of-state tuition
at Michigan and then got
a job as a dishwasher.
But anyway, so that's
how I got started.
I just really got
lucky because I
stumbled into work that I really
loved and into great people.
So Paul Saginaw, who's
been my partner in all this
from the get-go, was the general
manager at that restaurant.
Frank Carollo, who's one of the
partners at our bakery, where
all those things
that you, I think--
are you eating all
those pastries?
AUDIENCE: They might be gone.
ARI WEINZWEIG:
They might be gone.
Are they gone?
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
ARI WEINZWEIG: So
one thing is you
can keep eating while I talk.
Because my whole day is
spent talking to people
that are eating, and it makes
me nervous if you're not eating.
Because, well, it's
a sign that we're
headed to go out of business.
So anyway, and then
Maggie Bayless,
who's one of the partners
at ZingTrain, our training
business, who, actually, I
was just talking to on the way
here, was a cocktail waitress.
So I don't know why we're
all in there together,
but we've now known each
other probably twice as
long as a lot of you
all have been alive.
And that's a really
good problem to have.
And I feel fortunate for that.
So Frank started teaching me how
to prep and how to line cook.
And I started managing
kitchens, and I
worked for that restaurant
group for about four years.
Paul left about
halfway through that
and opened Monahan's
Seafood Market,
which, if you don't
know it, is still
one of the best fish markets in
the country, over in Kerrytown.
And fall of '81, I reached
a point, which is not
uncommon in the
world, where it's not
like I hated going to work, and
they were not a bad company,
but I was just sort
of less and less
inspired by what I was doing.
And I could sense more and
more clearly every week
that where they were
headed organizationally,
with food philosophy and
leadership philosophy,
were not where I wanted to head.
So I just decided I was going
to give two months' notice.
I didn't know what was next.
And Paul called
me two days later.
And he said that there was
this little building coming
open near the fish market.
How many people have
been to the deli?
Almost everybody.
OK, so he had grown
up in Detroit, where
you could get good deli food.
And in Chicago,
you could get it,
but you couldn't get it here.
So we decided, like, in a
week, we were going to open.
And four and a half months
later, we were open--
which, I don't really know how
we did it because today, it
literally can take four months
to get a meeting set up when
we're both not doing anything.
But anyway, that's
how we started.
So that was March 15, 1982.
It was me and Paul and two
employees and a space smaller
than this room.
And today, we have--
I mean, minuscule by
Google standards--
700 employees, plus
we hire like 300 more
at the holidays for mail
order and for the bakehouse.
And we're tiny by your
standards but large by ours.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: So starting
off as a dishwasher
with a Russian history
degree from U Mich
and understanding how to be a
businessman in the restaurant
industry, what got you into
writing books and becoming
an author?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well,
I started writing--
I don't know, it was probably
mid-'80s-- because I was
frustrated with the people who
were writing our newsletter
for us.
And I'm sure the fault
was mine, not theirs.
But it just wasn't
saying things really
the way I wanted
them to get said.
And I think one of
them gave notice.
And so I decided I was just
going to do it by myself.
And that's how I
started writing.
So I never intended to
be a writer, either.
I just needed to write
in order to communicate
what we were trying to do.
So that's really
how I got started.
And then I wrote
the newsletter for I
don't know how many years.
But I started to get really
positive feedback from people.
And I sort of blew it off.
And people kept
encouraging me to do more.
And then people started
saying, you should do a book.
It's so easy.
You already wrote
everything, which,
of course, is not accurate.
But when you don't actually
have to do the work,
everything seems easy
from the outside.
But anyway, I had gotten enough
encouragement that probably
by the mid-'90s, I decided that
if I were going to do that,
I needed to actually
learn more about writing.
Because I didn't really
know anything about writing,
in particular, other than
what everybody in this room
knows about it.
And so I started to read
books about writing.
I got in a writing group,
which was super helpful.
And I did that for 10 years.
And over the course
of that time,
then we self-published
a little book
on olive oil and a
little book on vinegar,
which got really good response.
And then, that turned
into "Zingerman's Guide
to Good Eating," which came
out with Houghton, Mifflin.
And then it all kind
of went from there.
Except I didn't really like
the big publishing world.
And so after the
"Guide to Good Eating,"
we pretty much pulled back
into doing all our own.
So we do all the design.
We print them here in Ann Arbor.
I'm not a big Amazon fan, so
we try to stay off of there.
And that's sort of the
farm-to-table version of books.
So it started with food
writing, and then I
wrote a book about
customer service,
and then I wrote a
book about bacon.
And then the leadership
book started, actually,
as articles which then,
later, turned into books.
So now there's a lot of books.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: There
are a lot of books.
So speaking of
those books, you've
written a series of four--
ARI WEINZWEIG: Yeah,
there's more to come still.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Awesome.
Well, we'll be on the
lookout for those.
So some of those, to
just give a name to them,
are "Building a Great Business,"
"Being a Better Leader,"
"Managing Ourselves,"
and lastly--
which is your most recent book--
"The Power of
Beliefs in Business,"
which is our focus
for today's talk.
So can you tell us where
did the idea or inspiration
to write a book about beliefs
in business come from?
ARI WEINZWEIG: I can.
We don't have a little
white sheet, though, do we,
to draw on?
DOMINIQUE EHRL: We do.
ARI WEINZWEIG: We do.
Right over there.
So I'm going to show you
what the inspiration was.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Yes, please do.
ARI WEINZWEIG: But it sounds
weird because I speak all over,
and I teach a lot, and we
teach a lot internally.
But I had actually never thought
about the impact of beliefs
on, really, anything up until
I discovered-- thank you--
this cycle, which I'll show you.
And so when I talk
about beliefs,
I'm not talking about
religion, sports, and politics,
which are the three areas
of beliefs that people
go on about incessantly,
although no one ever
changes their belief.
They just talk about it.
But this is about beliefs--
you got a little pen, too?
Perfect.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
ARI WEINZWEIG: It'll work.
This is about beliefs,
like about what
we believe about
human beings, what
computers, what we believe
about the price of a cup
of coffee or a brownie
or whatever.
So I learned this cycle from
Bob Wright, who's in Chicago.
And he can't remember
where he learned it,
so I don't really know who
to give ultimate credit to.
One of you's thinking, I'm
going to search this later.
And you're going to
email me this afternoon
and tell me where it came from.
But anyway-- I
look forward to it.
It's a self-fulfilling
belief cycle,
and it kind of blew my mind
when I learned it from him.
And it turned into
a 600-page book
because I kept studying
and studying and studying.
And I just kept
realizing more and more
the impact it was having.
And I realized it was
going on all around me,
and all around us, every day
and that it had enormous impact
on our organization and
on my life and that,
basically, because
of what we believe,
we are mostly creating
what happens around us.
So ready?
We all have beliefs.
Based on what we believe,
we all take action.
So literally, every
action that we take--
including you all
coming here today,
me coming to talk to you,
Dominique initiating this
conversation--
every action we take is
based on what we believe.
Based on our actions,
the people around us
start to form their own beliefs.
And based on their beliefs,
they, in turn, take action.
And what blew my mind is
that, like 95% of the time,
their action reinforces
our original belief.
And this is going on all day
long, all over the world,
everywhere, OK?
Does this make sense?
So two really quick
examples, one organizational.
So if you were to have a
leader of an organization--
probably not yours or ours--
but where the leader--
CEO, founder,
whatever-- he or she
doesn't believe in training.
What action would they take?
This is where you talk.
AUDIENCE: Deprioritize training.
ARI WEINZWEIG: They deprior--
oh, there's a good word,
Mara-- deprioritize.
So they deprioritize training.
They don't do any training.
That we say they don't do any.
[LAUGHTER]
We're not as advanced.
So when they don't
do any training,
what do the people
who work there start
to believe about the
organization's belief in them,
about the possibilities
for the future, et cetera?
AUDIENCE: There aren't any.
ARI WEINZWEIG: There aren't any.
When they believe there's
no positive future at hand,
what kind of work do they do?
AUDIENCE: Bad.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Bad work.
Very good.
They deprioritize
their work quality.
And the CEO, or
the leader, goes,
thank god we didn't waste
any money on training.
Look how bad these
employees are.
OK.
If you flip around the
belief of the leader,
then you get what we
do, which is-- whatever.
We have, like, 75
internal classes that we
teach in our organization.
So not the same class
taught 75 times--
75 different internal
classes for a pretty small
organization.
What do the people who work
there start to believe?
AUDIENCE: They can improve.
ARI WEINZWEIG: They can improve.
What else?
AUDIENCE: They're valued.
ARI WEINZWEIG: They're valued--
absolutely.
What kind of work do they do?
Really good work.
And we go, this training rocks.
Let's do a lot more.
The irony is it's exactly
the same employee base.
All that changed is the
belief of the leader.
The results are the opposite.
The people are the same.
This is all that changed.
On a super-simple,
seemingly stupid,
interpersonal
situation, has anybody
been in a work situation
where two people
weren't getting along?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Six of you have?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So let's just say
that Billy believes
that Alice is kind of a jerk.
How will he treat Alice
when he comes near her?
AUDIENCE: Poorly.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Poorly.
What will Alice now
believe about Billy?
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES] .
ARI WEINZWEIG: He's a jerk.
And what will she do
when he comes near?
Treat him poorly.
And he goes, it's
worse than I thought.
If Billy changes his belief
and he says, you know,
I'll bet she's just
shy-- she feels awkward
and uncomfortable, I remember
when I started how overwhelming
it was, it's hard to get all the
personalities down, et cetera,
she's probably a
totally good person,
but she just is anxious--
now what might he do
when he comes near her?
AUDIENCE: Be nice.
AUDIENCE: Say hi.
ARI WEINZWEIG: He might be nice,
welcome her, introduce himself.
Here's my email.
Here's my card, whatever.
What's she start to
believe about him?
AUDIENCE: Wow, he's nice.
ARI WEINZWEIG: He's a nice guy.
You're getting it, man.
Keep it going.
Now what's she do?
When he comes near,
how's she treat him?
AUDIENCE: Good.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Great.
And he goes, see, I knew
she was a nice person.
She was just anxious.
This cycle is going
on all over the world.
Countries go to war over it.
And that's not a exaggeration.
So this whole
thing blew my mind.
And once I started to
realize this was happening,
then I realized my own beliefs
were getting in the way.
Because the reality
is, where do you all
think beliefs come from?
It's not Amazon.
AUDIENCE: Your culture.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Yeah.
So we're not born with them.
Beliefs are not genetic.
It's all learned behavior.
We learn from people we trust.
So when we're little kids,
we don't know enough not
to fully trust our parents.
So we just take
everything they give us--
it's true-- and we believe it.
Then, as we grow up, we
start to get other inputs.
So it could be a teacher.
It could be your minister.
It could be a TV star, an
athlete, an actor, your best
friend on the playground,
your best friend's
parents-- whatever it is.
But all of those beliefs
are being formed, right?
And so we start to
take on information.
Sometimes it's through books.
That's how a lot of my
beliefs were formed.
So it could be from people
we never even met, right?
But the thing is that
we have the power
to change our beliefs.
So what's happening
here is changeable.
It's not genetic, right?
Two last things and
then we'll move forward.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: It's fine.
Go ahead.
ARI WEINZWEIG: So I started
to break beliefs out
into three broad categories.
Well, I started to
think about beliefs
as the root system of our lives
because you can't see them.
But you're guaranteed what's
happening below the ground
is 100% correlated to above.
So negative beliefs, neutral
beliefs, and positive beliefs.
And if beliefs are
the root system,
it's not rocket science.
What kind of outcomes do you
get from negative beliefs?
AUDIENCE: Weeds.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Negative
outcomes-- weeds, exactly.
Neutral beliefs don't do much.
Positive beliefs create
positive outcomes.
So the reality is that
I started to realize
is it's totally impossible
to get positive outcomes
from negative beliefs.
And that's true socially.
It's true interpersonally.
It's true in your family.
It's true of yourself.
And so then I
started to realize I
need to change the
negative beliefs I
have to positive
ones, which doesn't
mean there's no problems.
It's just you could
have positive beliefs
about a problem
or negative ones.
And then the last thing is--
for the moment-- in here is
there's a little filter that we
all have, which is
that we filter out
all information that doesn't
support what we already
believe.
And we seek out or take in
information that supports
what we already believe.
And that's why, when
you read the news,
half the country arrives at
the totally opposite conclusion
of the other half
of the country,
even though they read
exactly the same story.
Because they filter out.
They find evidence to
support what they already
believed in the first place.
And this is going
on all day long.
So that's just the beginning.
But there you go.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Thank you.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Thank you.
Did that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DOMINIQUE EHRL:
Wonderful, thanks.
So off of that, I
guess, encouragement
to change our beliefs,
to think more positively,
to root ourselves in
positive beliefs, what advice
do you have for us
when maybe we start
to doubt those beliefs
that we've formed?
We start to maybe not
believe in the product,
the person, the organization?
How do we stop that and
prevent it when it happens?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well, I'm not
saying you shouldn't doubt it.
I mean, it could be that
there's good reason to doubt it.
It's just to explore the doubt.
Rollo May, the very
fascinating-- to me, at least--
mid-20th century psychologist,
said the opposite of courage
is not cowardice.
It's conformity.
And I think that's true.
And so I think part
of what happens
is that beliefs become
commonly accepted
and then they go with the flow.
So this is true
all over the world.
Your beliefs can
change, but they
won't change until you come
in contact with information
that's incongruous with what
you already believed, right?
So that could be
true personally.
You could have stereotyped
somebody very easily.
Things like racism,
anti-Semitism, these
are all negative beliefs
that are socially
supported in many communities.
And I don't believe
people set out to do ill.
But that's the belief
that's all around them,
and that's what
they grow up with,
and that's what they
accept as the norm
until they get themselves
into a different context.
So I have a lot of, through
Southern Foodways Alliance,
which is a really
great nonprofit--
like, I'm from Chicago.
I mean, in hindsight, I
had very negative beliefs
about the South because I grew
up in the civil rights era.
Coming from Chicago,
going to the South
was not something I would
really have imagined.
But through Southern
Foodways Alliance,
it has really changed my
beliefs, in hindsight,
about the South and to
understand the real diversity
of what's going on and to
understand the culture more
in-depth, et cetera.
But anyway, I have a lot
of friends from there
who said that their parents
grew up in very racist settings.
And I said, well, what happened?
And they're like, well, my mom
said when she went to college,
it totally changed everything.
Why?
Because if you grow up in a
town where that's the norm,
why would you question it?
You hear it from everybody you
know, everybody you look up to.
And then, when they got
in a different setting,
they realized the falsity and
negativity of that belief.
But until some other
input comes in,
you don't know enough
to question it.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Thanks.
So is there a consequence
to positive beliefs?
Is there a way
you can overdo it?
And how do we balance that?
ARI WEINZWEIG: My point
is not to be Pollyanna.
So I'm not saying
there's no problems.
I just, like I said,
I think that you
could have a positive
belief about a problem
or a negative belief.
So one of the stories
I use for that a lot
is the story of Food
Gatherers, which is
from before you all were here.
But in 1988, there
were a lot of people
going hungry in Ann Arbor.
So a negative belief would
have been the system sucks,
society sucks, people are
selfish, this is hopeless,
there's nothing we
can do, it's horrible.
A positive belief is
the one that Paul had,
which was, this is
horrible, but we
can use what we
learned in business
to create a organization that'll
actually do something about it.
And that organization
became Food Gatherers, which
now, whatever, delivers like
five-plus million pounds
of food in Washtenaw County.
So the problems are the same.
It's just the negative belief
leads to more negativity.
It's as accurate, in
many ways, but it's not
leading to a positive outcome,
whereas a positive belief
about the same situation can
create something meaningful.
So I don't know.
I mean, it's hard to know.
There's no black and white
answer to what's real, right?
I mean, I didn't study
existentialist philosophy,
but we might not even be
here right now, right?
But what was once considered
completely impossible
is now considered normal.
Witness what you all
do every day, right?
So when you go back in history,
things that we take for granted
were not common.
American women who married
were no longer legally
allowed to be teachers up
until, like, the 1920s, right,
which sounds insane.
But that's what it was.
Native Americans didn't get
to vote till, I think, 1927.
So I mean there's just all
sorts of things in history
that, when you
really go in there,
that people believed to be
normal and appropriate that now
would seem completely crazy.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: So switching
gears a little bit,
there's a large theme in
the book surrounding hope.
Can you speak about how
we make hope happen?
ARI WEINZWEIG: I can.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, hope is another
subject that I really
never thought about.
I mean, obviously,
I know about it.
But it turns out that we
can actively create hope,
and we can often
unwittingly crush hope.
And it turns out,
from now having
studied it some, that,
not shockingly, people
with low hope
don't do good work.
You all and we all are in
a very high-hope setting.
With all of the
not-inappropriate conversation
around privilege and
everything in society,
what I've sort of come to
realize is that the two things
you can't overcome--
you can overcome
all the other bias
if you have a little bit of
support and a lot of work--
but nobody can overcome
lack of positive beliefs.
And nobody can
overcome lack of hope.
So when you have no hope,
you'll never do work.
Because there's no point.
And unfortunately,
a lot of workplaces,
leaders are unwittingly
smashing hope.
Some of them might
know they're doing it.
But a lot of them mean well.
But they don't even
know they're doing it.
So then I started
to look at, how
do you go to the positive,
which is how do you create hope?
Because most of us
in this room are
coming from high-hope settings,
and so we take it for granted.
And I started to look
at hope metaphorically,
like the sun, because when
there's no sun, nothing grows.
So the six things-- there's
a essay on this hope star
because sun, star was
too hard to pass up.
Going from memory,
so the first is
to help people see a more
positive future, right?
The second one,
though, is to see
paths to get to that future.
Because if you could
see a positive future
but you have no clue
how to get there,
it's just magical thinking.
And it doesn't
actually help anybody.
And it turns out high-hope
people have multiple paths
to get there.
Low-hope people
will often have one,
and then something
goes wrong, and then
they see it as the end.
So in hindsight, the
story of me applying
at that restaurant three
times is an indication
that I grew up in a
high-hope setting.
Because somebody from
a low-hope background
would be equally
skilled as I was--
which wasn't
particularly skilled--
but they would be
equally skilled as I was.
But when you're coming
from a low-hope setting,
you would give up, whereas
I just figured, whatever.
I got to get a job.
Go back, right?
And so I'm guessing that's true
for a lot of people in here.
Because we have this
advantage, socially,
of being raised in high-hope
settings because we're
surrounded by high-hope people.
So first is better future.
Second is how to get there.
Third thing would be to see how
they matter as human beings.
So this is not connected to
what they do for a living.
It's just that the person, he or
she themselves, are important,
right?
The fourth is how
their work matters.
The fifth thing is
to help people see
how the little things matter.
Because high-hope people
do the little things.
And that's actually what
gets you to success.
The low-hope people keep
waiting, in essence,
to win the lottery
of life somehow--
waiting for the right person,
waiting for the right job,
waiting for the right agent,
whatever-- whereas the people
with high hope tend to
do the little things
because they believe in
a more positive future.
And the sixth is to see
how we fit into something
greater than ourselves.
And that could be
an organization.
It could be a department
within an organization.
It could be your family.
It could be your church.
It could be any group
that you feel a part of.
But everybody, I think,
wants to be part of something
greater than themselves.
And if you think
about it, I realize
there's a natural
tension between you
matter as an individual
and you're part of a group.
So there's always
this creative tension.
So when you look,
like in history,
when you look back at
fascism or communism,
they were extreme examples
of where you fit in a group,
but you don't matter.
So the individual
in those contexts
is completely irrelevant.
It's only about the group.
So the key is to try to have
a creative tension where
the individual is important
and a group construct is also
important at the same time.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Amazing.
Thank you.
So going off of beliefs and
having hope and nurturing
hope, having leaders
invest in creating hope,
why isn't everyone
already doing this?
When you go train for
ZingTrain and talk
to smaller businesses
about these concepts,
what is the biggest pushback?
Why is this so difficult?
ARI WEINZWEIG: I don't know
that we get a ton of pushback.
I mean, the people
that come to us
have some inkling or belief
that there's some merit to it,
or else they wouldn't come.
Ironically, of course, the
people who need us the most
are the least likely to come.
Because they
believe, why would we
go to Zingerman's when we could
go to Harvard Business School
or whatever?
Gustave Landauer was a
very interesting anarchist,
a German Jewish pacifist
who was kicked to death
by the German Army in 1919.
And in one of the
pieces that he wrote,
he said, people
ask all the time,
why don't people already
do all this stuff?
And he said they don't do it
because their parents didn't
do it.
Managers learn
from other managers
who learned from
other managers who
learned from other managers.
In the same way that
stuff becomes the norm,
they just have that
belief that that's OK--
and then also out of ignorance.
I don't know.
There's not a lot of books out
there on hope in the workplace.
So where would people
have heard of it, right?
And I guess, like in
my context of food,
if you never had a really
amazing oatmeal raisin cookie,
then the one they sell
you at the 7-Eleven
tastes totally fine.
Because that's the
context that you have.
It's only when you
experience something
in the quality of workplace,
in the quality of relationship,
in the quality of
human interaction
that tells you there could
be more that you go for more.
When everybody around
you hates their job, when
every boss you had
treated you badly,
when everybody's image of
beliefs about work is it's
a total drag and you
shouldn't have to do it,
and you only have to do it if
you're too poor to not do it,
then the odds of getting a great
experience are almost zero.
But once you start to
experience something else that's
more positive, then you
don't really go back.
But I think, even with
all that, most people
in most organizations just
aren't thinking about it.
It doesn't come up.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Thank you.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Thank you.
Now you're thinking about it.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: I am, actually.
Now, it makes a lot of sense.
All right.
So I want to switch
gears a little bit again.
So just for some context, all of
us here are very client-facing,
and we deal with
people all day long.
ARI WEINZWEIG: You are.
Because you're looking at
me, and I use your stuff.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: You got it.
So Zingerman's, again, has
been coined as the biggest
cool small company in America.
And can you tell us a little
bit about how customer service
weaves into this story,
and what businesses
can learn from a
service industry
like Zingerman's, and
how we can use that
in our day-to-day roles
here, even at Google?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well, we
didn't bring it today,
but I wrote a little
book about service, too.
But I think service is service.
I don't think it matters
whether you're online
or you're selling rice from
a street stand in Jamaica.
I think it's all
service is service.
So I think a lot of--
really all of-- what
we do, whether it's the
stuff around beliefs,
on hope, on customer
service, on visioning,
on open book management, I
mean, they're basically just
universal human principles.
And I think that adopting
service as a life approach
is actually the key.
Because when we live service
as strictly just to get money,
it's like marrying for money.
In theory, it could work.
But the odds of it being--
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I mean, it's
not emotionally
sustainable over a
long period of time
because you don't
really believe in it.
And in theory, it got
you what you wanted.
But you feel hollow
inside because you're not
pursuing what you really
are aligned with ethically
and spiritually and soulfully.
And it's the same with service.
So I think most of us--
you know, Mara
could add in if she
wants-- but I think most of
us that work with the service
approach is it just
becomes how we live.
And I treat my girlfriend
in the same three
steps to great service that
I would use with you all.
And it's just because
it's a nicer way to live.
And I think, in that
context, in hindsight--
you're probably going to
get to it because you've
done such a good
job of reading--
but the spirit of
generosity stuff,
it all feeds with
service, right?
So service is spirit
of generosity.
And when we choose to live
every day and every interaction
as best we can, and perfectly
with the spirit of generosity,
then I think the
world goes better.
And I think our lives go
better as the people doing it.
And that is what service is.
So in the book, there's
three steps to great service
and five steps the handling a
complaint, which is basically
a recipe to actualize
what is a good intent
but most people don't
know how to make happen.
So yeah.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Awesome.
So off of that, all of us
have had those interactions
with customers where we
weren't even mean to them.
We were the nicest
we've ever been.
But we can't control
how they react.
ARI WEINZWEIG: We
have those same ones.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Yeah.
And a lot of times,
there's yelling.
There's nowhere productive.
The direction of the
conversation's not productive.
What is your advice, in being
in this business of service,
to get back on your feet?
After those
interactions, how do we
keep going and living
a service-driven life?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well, it's hard.
So in the first book,
there's an essay called
"12 Natural Laws of Business."
And one of them
is that strengths
lead to weaknesses
and also vice versa.
So if you care a lot,
that's a strength.
The weakness will be that it's
hard to not take it personally.
If you really don't care
about the customers,
and they act like
jerks, then it's
just a self-fulfilling
negative belief.
And you're like, I
knew they were jerks.
Whatever.
Who cares?
So I don't know.
I mean, my dog died
three years ago.
And she was 17.
And it totally sucks, right?
If anybody's been through
that, it's the worst.
But the alternative is not
to care and not to have
had the good relationship.
And it's the price of having
a good relationship is
that the pain is connected
with the positive.
So I guess it's just
finding ways to self-manage,
which is the third book.
For me, it's the
things that I do--
try to be around good people.
So who can I talk to that's
going to help me reground?
I can't always do
it but running--
I run every day.
In fact, I'm leaving
here to go run.
It helps me to reground.
In the old days,
I used to just--
I don't actually have
an office or a desk,
but I used to stash positive
thank you notes and stuff
that people had given me.
I would leave them in my
mailbox so that then I just
had stuff laying around.
There's just little
things that can help.
Breathing helps a lot.
There's no right way.
I'm an introvert,
so I generally want
to get away from everybody.
Some of you all are
extroverts, so that's the worst
thing you could imagine.
But the point is to know
yourself well enough
to know how to reground.
And it's easy for everybody to
say, don't take it personally.
But if you care, you're going
to kind of take it personally.
And then, this
taught me, actually,
to remember that they're
not jerks when they do that.
Most of those people are
just having a rough time.
And I try to remind
myself what's true,
which is I only had to deal
with them for 20 minutes.
And I'm not being
flip, but they've
got to live that way
the rest of their life,
or at least they've lived
that way their whole life.
And the people that
are close to them
are dealing with that every day.
And that's way worse
than the little snippet
that I got stuck with.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Thank you.
So lastly on customer
service, can you
touch on, a little bit,
about what fairness
is in customer service?
I actually did read.
ARI WEINZWEIG: You did
do a good job of reading.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: I did read
your customer service book.
So you talk about fairness.
I think that was
a awesome concept.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well, I
realized that we all grow up--
or most of us grow
up-- with this concept
that life's supposed to be fair.
And we spend a lot of
time when we're little
telling our parents that
stuff's not fair and--
anybody done that?
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, but then I
realized, with service, it's
not fair because of exactly
what you just described.
And you or I could
give amazing service,
and we could get
treated really badly,
having nothing to do with
us or the content of what
we provided.
It's just what's happening.
And it could be that that
person's significant other
is in the emergency room,
and they're flipping out.
It could be that their mother
just got diagnosed with--
I mean, anything
could have happened,
and we don't really know, right?
So we started to teach people
that fair is another planet,
and we're not on it, and that
if you need things to be fair,
service is the wrong
profession to be in.
Because I think in
the long-run, it's
going to work out for
everybody for the better.
But in the moment,
it's not really fair.
And it's just the way it works.
And we can't control
anything, let alone
what the customer does.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Great.
So in the books,
you have sprinkled
in a lot of exercises.
So I was hoping
that maybe you would
be able to pick one
of your favorites,
and maybe we can all take
a minute to take a stab.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Oh, wow.
Very good, Dominique.
OK.
Do you all have
something to write with?
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Phones.
AUDIENCE: Typewriters.
AUDIENCE: Oh, god.
[LAUGHTER]
DOMINIQUE EHRL: This is tech.
Just kidding.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Do you
all know each other?
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Yeah.
ARI WEINZWEIG:
What should we do?
Three and Out?
I was going to have
them do This I Believe.
It's kind of hard to do
without writing, though.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Maybe
just talk about it,
something that we can hold
on to and practice later.
Just thought it would be fun.
ARI WEINZWEIG: OK, so This I
Believe is in the new book.
I named it after the 1953,
I think, CBS radio series
with Edward R. Murrow, which
became an NPR series also,
and came out in a
couple of books.
But it's basically a way to tap
your beliefs about anything,
right?
So the exercise would
be just to sit down--
or, I guess, you
could stand up-- but
to sit down and, for
three minutes, list,
as fast as you can
write, everything
you believe about any
situation, person,
or whatever is in your mind.
So if you have a situation
you're struggling with at work,
at home, interpersonal,
project management,
whatever it might be,
do, like, three minutes.
And the faster you write,
the better it works.
So don't think about it.
Write.
And then it's just interesting
what will come out.
The reality is, because of
what I already told you,
what you write today will
be different than what
you would have written
yesterday, which is OK.
But just, the more
we learn, it's
already changing
your beliefs based
on that little interaction.
So that's one that
I would really--
I've started to
do it for anything
I'm having a challenge with.
Because I'm better at it now.
But you just realize,
I have negative beliefs
about whoever-- my cousin,
my neighbor, or whatever
it might be.
And it doesn't mean you
have to change them.
But it just means if you
want a different outcome,
it's unlikely to arrive without
a different set of beliefs.
Internal training
at Zingerman's.
Not my own training of myself.
I have that, too.
AUDIENCE: For your employees.
What are some other ways
you inspire positive belief
amongst your employees?
Because they are
so super friendly
and seem to stick around
for a really long time.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well, I
think there's no one thing.
I think that's really
the point of the books
is that from studying
the anarchists
and restudying it actively over
the last five or seven or eight
years, the world at
large has been trained
to think hierarchically.
And I guess-- I don't know
if this is antithetical
to the Google logarithm, but--
so when you get trained
to think hierarchically--
I'm not saying you're doing
this-- but the world at large
is looking for this
singular answer.
They want to know your biggest
success, the key secret,
the biggest failure, what's
the number one thing?
And I think that thinking
is the biggest problem.
Because I started to look-- as
per the idea of beliefs as root
system--
I started to look at
organizations as ecosystems.
And in nature, there
is no hierarchy.
It's actually unnatural
to create hierarchy.
And so I think in a
ecosystem in nature,
in a healthy ecosystem,
everything matters.
Seemingly small
things matter far more
than you might
imagine, like bees,
which, by weight,
would be infinitesimal
but have an enormous
positive or negative impact.
And looking for one
singular thing doesn't work.
So I think getting people
in a healthy ecosystem--
I'm sure you're
experiencing it here
because you have friends
who don't work here,
and they have a very
different work experience--
treating people with dignity
and respect from day one.
So again-- and maybe
it's my anarchist thing,
maybe it's something
else-- but I'm not
any better than the newest
dishwasher that we hired.
They know a lot I don't know.
And they have a
lot of good ideas.
And I don't know
what they are yet.
So I think that matters a lot.
Teaching all this
stuff to everybody--
so you don't have to
be senior management
to learn about this stuff.
We just try to teach everybody.
We're open book.
I think just by teaching
people about beliefs--
it's not like
people go, I'm going
to have a lot of
negative beliefs
today and see how that goes.
They don't even know
they have beliefs.
So they're not trying to do ill.
They just don't even know.
So I think all of
that's happening.
We give copies of
the business books,
if people want to read,
for no charge, really.
And then, I think,
culturally, it
makes an enormous difference
who you're around.
So it'll come up
in the culture now
because people who have been
there will say something.
So all that and more.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I was at the Roadhouse.
And I was with family
from out of town.
And we love the experience.
My niece ordered a bagel, and
it took 30 minutes to come.
And that was kind of
a terrible experience,
and they kind of left feeling
negatively about the server.
I had a great experience
with the server
because he brought
the check and said,
can I get you anything else?
And I jokingly said,
a shot of whiskey.
And mind you, it's noon.
He came back with the check
and a shot of whiskey.
It was great.
And so I'm just curious,
from a coaching standpoint,
if you're the
manager or the person
on staff and you witness
something, maybe,
here, like a discrepancy in
how a server handled something,
and you see something bad
versus something good, what
do you do to then inspire
hope or remedy the situation
or coach when you
witness this happening?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well,
with the bagel,
I don't know what happened.
I mean, there's 1,000 things
that could have gone wrong.
And inevitably, they happen,
as frustrating and unfortunate
as it is.
Is that what you're
asking, about that?
Or you're asking about
that he gave you whiskey?
AUDIENCE: More from a
leadership standpoint,
when you notice an
employee made a mistake--
in the, positive belief
about a negative situation.
ARI WEINZWEIG: It probably
is to normalize mistakes.
So I make 100 every day.
I think one of the
fallacious beliefs
that American, and
probably most societies,
create is that leaders aren't
supposed to make mistakes,
which, of course, is stupid.
Because we're all making
them all the time.
And with all due
respect to those of us
in formal leadership
roles, we don't really
know what we're doing, either.
So I think it's
never giving feedback
from some sort of
hierarchically superior place.
It's just like, this is what
I noticed in the same way
they're going to notice
stuff that I didn't do well.
And then, more to
focus on the positive.
And we have a ratio
that we recommend
of four parts praise to one
part constructive criticism.
And that was supported by a
study, which some people later
doubted the data but
intuitively makes sense to me,
which is the Losada study--
L-O-S-A-D-A-- where they found
all successful organizations
had a minimum of 2.9 parts
positive communication to one
part of criticism.
That was the minimum.
So I think focusing
on the positive.
So if I knew who
gave you this shot,
I would give him
a big compliment.
Because it takes guts
to do that, and that's
what we want people to do.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It'll stick with me forever.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Yep.
Did you drink it?
AUDIENCE: Oh, absolutely.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Ari, the
Zingerman's company
has got so many great companies.
There's bakery,
restaurant, printing press,
et cetera-- training.
How do you take an idea, and
how do those get started?
If you have an idea--
there's not a great home
delivery food company.
What do you do with that?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well,
still, for a business,
the ideas really come from
the person who has the idea.
So I have a million ideas.
I think the ideas, actually,
are super easy and not
hard to come up with.
The hard part's, who's
going to do it for 20 years?
And so what we've found is
it's easier to find the idea
than it is to find the person.
So Miss Kim is our
newest business,
which is our Korean
restaurant in Kerrytown.
So that's probably five or six
years of work by Ji Hye with us
to get to where we opened.
And that process
includes writing
visions, which would be another
way to focus on the positive
that I didn't mention before,
a lot of interactivity
because when you're
working collaboratively,
you need to be able to
incorporate other people's
ideas, yet stand true to your
own, et cetera, et cetera.
And that's how they come.
Internally, for smaller
things, the biggest thing is--
there were a few of those
Bottom Line Change pamphlets
over there.
So we have a change methodology.
And because a lot
of our approach
is to teach everybody how
to lead from the minute
they start working and
not wait until they
get a title, which doesn't
really mean anything,
that the idea is that when
somebody has an idea that they
can lead the change.
Now, they may not be
the decision-maker,
but that doesn't stop them
from leading the change.
And so my job becomes to coach
them in how to lead the change,
not to implement their
idea for them, which
is, I would suggest, very
parental and paternalistic
and not very helpful.
It's better than not
implementing their idea,
but I think the real thing
is to learn how to lead.
And the pushback
is, well, people
aren't going to listen to me.
I'm like, dude, they don't
listen to me, either.
That's what leadership is, is
how do you get people on board?
Because there's
always resistance.
So that's the two,
for a business
and for a smaller change.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thanks for coming today.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Thanks.
Thanks to you for coming today.
AUDIENCE: You're welcome.
It was my pleasure.
It's clear that the culture,
the beliefs, the people
are core assets.
But I would argue that one
of your biggest assets is
the visual design brand
around Zingerman's-- the font,
the posters, the illustrations.
How did that come about?
And how do you
keep that thriving?
I love it.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Yeah.
Thank you.
I agree with you.
Well, strengths
lead to weaknesses,
and weaknesses can
lead to strength.
So when we started,
we had no money.
Today, everybody could
do food photography
and you all could have--
in this room, at least--
you could have a website
up by 3 o'clock.
But in those days, we
didn't have any money.
So food photography,
it used to cost $10,000
to have somebody come for a
day and shoot food photography.
So we just had our
friends and whoever
was working there start
making stuff by hand
because that was
what we could afford.
And then we just
basically used what's
now called "found materials,"
like cardboard boxes
that the lettuce came in,
to make signs and stuff.
So that's really
where it came from.
And then it evolved over time.
That handwriting
is the handwriting
of a guy named Steve Muno, who
worked for us for a long time.
He's long since moved on
and is a very nice guy.
But that was his handwriting.
It still is his handwriting.
And Mara can do it, I think.
But I am not able to.
But many people
learned how to do it.
Probably-- I don't know
when it was, 10 years ago--
the artist succumbed and allowed
it to be made into a font,
although they are adamant,
and I agree with them,
that you can tell--
I can tell-- the difference
when it's been done by hand
and when it's been
done off the font.
But the font is helpful
for somebody like me,
who can't reproduce it, and I'm
in a hurry doing some whatever.
And then, as we grew,
then we stumbled into--
we unwittingly fell into--
the problem of the look that
had become the norm at the deli
started to get not reproduced
in the other businesses, which
led to a lot of frustration
and then realizing, from working
with Maggie at ZingTrain a lot
over the years,
she's taught me when
you have a big
frustration with somebody,
it's almost always because you
have an unspoken expectation.
And then the challenge is to
look inwards and figure out
what that unspoken
expectation is.
And then it was
like, well, yeah,
this is the way
Zingerman's needs to look
and then being able to then
teach that more actively
and train people
in how to do it.
And then, within the
context of the hope stuff,
is use one look for
the whole organization
but then allow each business
to have its own manifestation
of that within the
overall look so that you
can honor the individuality
of the business
but not lose the coherence
of the organization overall.
AUDIENCE: Beautiful.
As a design guy, I
loved hearing that.
Thank you.
ARI WEINZWEIG: OK.
Cool.
Well, the epilogue of the
new book is about my belief
that business is like art and
that done well, it's good art,
and done poorly, it's bad
art, and so that, really,
all of the things that
go into design, I think,
go into making a
healthy organization.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: It'll
be our last question.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
A lot of pressure.
ARI WEINZWEIG: Harris, man,
no pressure at all, dude.
AUDIENCE: A lot of pressure.
So when you were talking
about the belief thing,
I was just curious,
from your point of view,
I feel like it's very common for
all of us, as you were saying,
to fall into the circle.
How do you go about identifying
when you fall into that rut,
whether it's you or
someone close to you?
And then a quick
follow-up to that,
how do you mitigate that to
change the path of the circle?
ARI WEINZWEIG: Well, there's
a recipe in the new book
for how to change a belief.
Because it's easier
said than done.
If you've had a belief
since you were six,
the roots are very deep, and
they don't change easily.
And this is why you can see it
in society all over the world.
I mean, people will
hold to their belief
even though the evidence
clearly shows it's wrong.
But they'll hold to their
beliefs anyways, right?
So when-- was it
Copernicus or Galileo?--
when he said that the sun didn't
revolve around the earth--
which, now, we go, oh,
well, of course the earth
revolves around the sun.
But they used to believe the
sun revolved around the earth.
So when he wrote that in his
book, the Catholic church said,
well, you can't write that.
It's wrong.
In the Bible, it says
it's the other way.
And he said, yeah, but
this is what's true.
They said, we don't care.
You have to take it out.
So when people have held
a belief for a long time,
generally, they will work
really hard to maintain
the belief in the face
of all sorts of evidence.
I think, for me,
it just made me get
myself to almost automatically
go, what do I believe?
And then, I'm like, oh, yeah,
I believe they can't do it.
Well, if I believe they
can't do it, they're doomed.
Because if I'm their manager,
they're not going to succeed.
So then I need to
re-examine my own belief.
In terms of other people--
here's the thing-- is you can't
make anybody change a belief.
It's a internal process.
And part of what tends
to happen socially
is people argue with others
that they should change
their belief, which
I would suggest just
makes the roots go deeper.
Even if they're wrong, it just
And this is why people--
I mean, this is the national
political scene right now.
No one's going to
change their mind.
The roots are just going
to go deeper and deeper.
And I know where I stand.
But it's not going to convince
anybody else to change
their mind that
doesn't agree with me.
So I think, in the end
of the day, all we can do
is model and share information
and hope for the best.
Because you can't force anybody.
I have the most
impact on my own self.
And that's really where
I can make a difference.
And if I change my
beliefs for the better,
then it might change
two other people,
and it might change
two other people.
But I don't think there's any--
there's no global,
universal solutions.
There's just people.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Can we give
Ari a round of applause?
Thank you.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ARI WEINZWEIG: Thank you.